[Musique]
je suis le président des fermes auberges
du haut-rhin je suis exploitants
agricoles paysans dans la vallée de la
thur et l'été on exploite une ferme
auberge prédit marc stein le métier de
fermiers aubergistes bien sûr c'est une
tradition une montagne budget ni par les
marcaires il depuis plus de 100 ans sont
là haut qui entretiennent ces espaces et
qui sont devenus des permis aux bergers
dans les années 70 crémieux bergie c'est
d'abord être paysan produire transformer
valoriser sur place et remettre dans
l'assiette ou dans le panier à emporter
de notre clientèle est bien sûr notre
vocation des totalement en phase avec
l'esprit cool puisque nous travaillons
de la fourche à la fourchette c'est à
dire du pré à l'assiette est vraiment le
fondement de notre métier avant tout
être à gunther est d'accueillir et
expliquer notre nature et notre montagne
à notre clientèle une valorisons un
territoire une part des produits de
qualité en gardant des espaces ouverts
de qualité aussi
et ce qui contribue totalement à
l'attractivité de ce territoire là et je
crois que l'ensemble des fermiers
aubergistes on est une soixantaine sur
le massif contribuer à ce que cette
économie locale de montagne soit durable
et continue bien sûr à installer des
jeunes générations après nous et qui
nous permet bien sûr d'être totalement
dans l'air du temps
bien qu'on le fasse depuis des
générations